they created a human shield along the
road to marab north of beirut
that's where the head of the christian
lebanese forces party samir jaja lives
he was supposed to appear at the army
intelligence building to answer
questions related to the fighting in the
lebanese capital earlier this month that
killed several people
jasha's supporters say they are
protecting him from what they call an
unjust system
this must stop hezbollah occupation
iranian occupation hezbollah
leverage over the court over the
other judges over political
life should stop
long-time enemies the shia groups
hezbollah and amal on one side and the
christian lebanese forces on the other
accuse each other of starting that gun
battle the case is now in the hands of
the military court which human rights
groups say has been used by the
authorities to intimidate and retaliate
for political reasons
we do have very grave concerns about the
independence of those judges given that
they are subordinate to the executive
jazza described the judge fadia kiki who
summoned him as hezbollah's commissioner
in the military tribunal and his lawyers
are trying to remove him from the case
many here worry that the lebanese forces
party is being targeted because it is a
vocal challenger of what the opposition
calls the hezbollah dominated political
order some opposition leaders also
believe the case against zsa will be
used to bury the investigation into last
year's explosion at beirut port
hezbollah to ally amal accused tariq
bhitar the lead judge in that
investigation of political bias and want
him removed and it seems they want zhaja
convicted
there seemed to be attempts to give
zhaja political and maybe even religious
cover from the church this is not
acceptable samir zarza and all the
killers should be taken to the place
where they need to be
the growing confrontation between the
two sides has raised tensions that can
yet again lead to sectarian violence
it is a dangerous standoff senator
al-jazeera beirut